I thought I should acknowledge
how much confusion there is right now
in the country about what
we're supposed to do.
There's so much confusion
about how we should be
reacting to COVID-19,
a lot of mixed signals
from public officials.
The president says one thing,
many governors say another thing.
Even the nation's top
public health agency,
the CDC, has been inconsistent.
Check it out. In March, the CDC said
we didn't have to wear masks,
now they're saying we do.
Well I looked into it, and
a lot of recommendations
on the CDC's COVID-19
website are confusing.
For example, check this
out, they're saying
"wash your hands for 20 seconds
or five seconds if no one's watching."
Look at this, if someone
sneezes near you, punch the air.
That's yes, if you win
at Rock, Paper, Scissors,
the other person gets
the virus and you don't.
You can hook up with a stranger in a bar
as long a should remain
emotionally distant.
Well, I'm safe. (chuckles)
Since small children are low
risk for contracting COVID,
it is acceptable to use a baby
as a protective face mask.
That's wrong, I shouldn't, please,
don't pay attention to that one.
Run. Run and never come back.
Are you listening to me?
You have to disappear.
Get outta here! Go now!
If you used your time during
quarantine to write a novel,
learn Mandarin, or do anything productive,
just know that everyone hates you.
Although it is only one of many reasons
not to go near clowns, please be aware
that all clowns have coronavirus.
You can't get COVID in a hot tub,
or was it you can't get
pregnant? Let's say both
and also my parents are
out of town this weekend.
And finally, although
there's a low likelihood
of spreading COVID while
jogging without a mask,
at least put on a shirt
you (bleep) animal.
Well good luck figuring those out.
As I said, very confusing.